the hollow colored pom pom pom pom
delayed
on gene watches that one can wear a
program prizes twenty eight gold medals
and more on this for accuracy than any
other time these
launching the world's most honored
watches made and guaranteed by the
wanted with more what company
it's time for the launching product
television journal of the vital issues
that they are
the presentation of the lawn jane but
nor what scott
maker all
longed j
the world's most on it what
tammy
distinguished companion to the world on
earth laundry
good evening this is frank dot
our guest on the launching promise built
this evening is princess alexandra
profile
a direct descendant of the first
sorrowful russia
her father was exiled from dollars
russia because of his liberal view
princess profile can return to russia in
nineteen fifteen
lives uh... really early days of the
revolution
and with respect to be imprisoned by the
communists
in time tuesday to america
antisense work
for the liberation of our people
may i present princess profile
are co-editors arm
mister william bradford hilly editor of
the american marketing
mister henry have
political economist at associate editor
of newsweek magazine
the opinions expressed are necessarily
those of the speaker
clinton compartment
secretary actually testifying on june
twenty sixth before a congressional
committee
seven america's wall day
is not good well communism what with the
dictators in the kremlin but with the
phone
fashion russian nationalism
he said i'm wall
it is clear is that
that this process i think ropes and
consolidation
by which russia had grown in the last
five hundred years
from the dot you must compete with that
empire must be stopped
now do you agree with that statement the
issue
that's manning
at acting valley statement home
one think is wrong with it
optical
them and communism asthma wouldn't be
bouncing and humans and animals
ambient country where
there was some kind of
perhaps democracy for the people
what you think that this view of the
saudi tends to
consolidate the russian people with
fallon instead of recognizing the fact
that
a lot of them are calls to the stand and
he
eighty percent is supposed to be opposed
and probably more
and i don't think
and then many russians
as opposed to come
when i'm at least interested expansion
territorial expansion landing at the
time
what what is the edits out and dangerous
what what is the evidence ah... used to
get a fair that
standing for the rest
proposed over that's a long story
developing walked to
one considers sister
why one considered it's eighty percent
it's about their one hears that her
people who were
escaped from russia
from quantities of prisms from
there many sources of evidence
on which is being connecting
five various groups not
i think we deliver guns
what do you think is the main thing that
could be done to take advantage of that
situation
patent allies
propaganda calls
such as being carried on
succinctly
propaganda side
radio
the russian and so on
his grandmother passed away
what that uh...
i think the american people would like
to hear
something from you
delightful right here
a lot of things that we hear great deal
about a russian secret police
now america where nobody's afraid of a
policeman
the average american satisfied finds it
difficult to believe all the stories we
hear about the effectiveness of the
russian police
how is it possible for the russian
secret police to exert
process cara among the people
first of all it's a contradiction
you'll see on the fifth saw as the
secret police the optoma
and was there personnel of about five
thousand people
in russia today the
over two men
incline invading agents in supplements
the russian
com secret police he hasn't had many
how many people how many russians would
you estimate had been put in
concentration camps
well that estimate families eight varies
from
twelve
twenty eight million people
and how many were and
trip through a prominent political
prisoners were than an average year and
a desire
they can never exceeded much of the
fifty thousand
wasn't present and in exile someone
you asked
how it's possible to have been still so
much to do
first of all those king
credible policy
and so much typical energy cuz ingane
and leaders who will
thing that people need for everyday not
secondly
says and
date yet
harmful system of spying on one another
which the communists had managed to
develop
that's a refinement that undermine that
and that's something that's you police
system we ask them what's in there where
people who've been down staffers and
linda
spy
but not like it is not
let me ask you uh... it
once a
russian is put in a concentration camp
is there any hope of release to be
released any other to come back home
some
times some dot
after they come out they usually only
allowed to live in certain places at new
homes
most of them come up with subject
capel st
finished anybody they come out to
daschle
and very few do get out of
concentration camps that if they are
concentration camps that presently
ben hogan russia's president
cryptically anyway
than to provide them with certain facts
to a lot of american
wouldn't seem to giay with disbelief
that the large majority of the russian
people are opposed to the region
for example they
very well against germany
he had no off career moves the uh...
chinese communists are finding very well
they're not surrendering and masculine
the americans in korea
they seem to have a very good morale
and if the satellites have that but
morale it wouldn't be a good supposition
that the russian soldiers would have
and even better
uh... opens for
and i'm not being com
that six eight of the russian people
you also got to remember that a great
many of the younger people who were born
under communism
denny don't like the regime saying
welcome something different
but when it comes to
fighting and animated up five
any kind of government
net always found
during world war two
adding more most number of russians went
over and for me medford valium in
germany
to fight back against russia
they all
at the germans bank and the bruins
and it's a johnson babysat with the
russians they would
had a tremendous number of all of his
head lots of a million men
so you think of our propaganda were
right my feet were rife with every day
to get involved in the war why we would
have wholesale positions and they would
be a quick
live collapse of the regime there
perhaps
possibly hits m i certainly think the
propaganda women reaches the russians
and a great deal of the best now
at has an enormous effect
also if they knew what was going to
happen to you
preferences
and don't know if you know this is new
with its use
visitors but
i'm out there but in forty eighteen
forty-nine lake
used to come over to the american so
fifty sixty a day not only to me
and the reason for that is that nothing
special is being done for
they don't know what's going to happen
to them if they do does that put them
into the imagine so
factors that i figured your question
about the nature of the underground and
how we can make it more effective
when i read there
dorky and dusty escape
i got the impression that
questions where a gmat
conspiratorial people that there was
always a a large group that was against
the government and they look at myself
now after a day intersecting groupings
than ever and russia not doesn't
it's impossible for people to meet
diggin tool discussing
you'll be even liquidated or an actress
and him
if you look at what the
of writing a story about the terrible
camp admits to stop very few did
there
well uh... is their is there any
potential on both donates out and and
and has the ways in which we might
encourage do you think that our
propaganda is effective now
not something i think this is mike
first of all there's a religious
underground
and that really does exist
act
depending upon
quite a few things to be done this
temple propaganda what about the voice
of america alec is effective all
up to a wind albany all all the radio
stations
which is why the underbrush hardball
unquestionably reaching many people
but i do think that they're not
driving up the sample is ok and
summer-like dalal
as a final question i'd like to ask
that's just part of what you think
we could do now
can drive away what's the price that we
could take now to drive a wedge between
the kremlin and the russian people
and i think in europe
julia concept
think that if the representatives of the
famine in this country
but we did a little sensual auspices
instead of being invited to dinner
parties that they were ridiculed and
that's all
when that
on-demand i think that that might have
quite
so here is a yen summing up
he would say that there is a potential
underground and that properly encourages
it can be very hopeful for the western
world
i think so
i think it can be the most hopeful thing
in the world because it's probably
anyway optimal
thank you very much for being with us
they editorial board for this edition of
the launching from the scope laws
mister william bradford healy
and mister henry half
our distinguished guests
was princess alexandra pro popped
leveluk
but mom did magnifying glass that they
watch maker balls like a monocle in his
eye
is called the loop
after years of observing watches the
wall times new and old
the man with the lou
becomes an excellent judge what
and we're proud of the fine details
about launching watchers
which come to us everyday
problem long established what's right
technical communication great
the quality of launching watches these
beyond compare
as an experienced watch maker
the fine workmanship commands my
admiration
after years of observation of my own
jeans and other watches
high and convince that no watch gives so
much satisfaction as along g
no i'm not so long
yes indeed
the man with a little most while on the
march is that one can world's background
prizes
twenty eight gold medals
and so many others for accuracy and feel
so precise time
superlative holiday through and through
makes known jane
the world's most art walk
shrank night
inviting you to join us again next week
along jane profits go
at television journal of the important
issues of the hour
broadcast on behalf of
laundry
the world's most on it what
not undistinguished companion to the
world on it laundry
so and service
by more than four thousand leading to
others from coast to coast
who proudly display the emblem
agency logon game but know a lot
out
on june watches that one can wear a
program prices forty eight gold medals
than for others for accuracy than any
other parties
undo the world's most honored watches
made and guaranteed by the wanted what
mall watch company
meantime father launching
television journal of the implementation
of the house
partial you every monday and wednesday
and friday
presentation of the launching much more
what happens
later on
launching the world's most on it wont
and what
distinguished companion to the world on
and on gene
remained at the front line
man produce are co-editors for the
position on the lawn gene krantz co
that that whatever bradford doing editor
of the american marketing and mr donald
r roger as an editor of the new york
arab review
our distinguished guests for this
evening
is the honorable charles big problems
united states represented a prom india
the opinions expressed are necessarily
those of the speaker
congressman brad prior
crespo clients no use being young
freshman congressman a republican from
indiana
room so instrumental in defeating the
rule universal military training bill
now we all know that the bill has been
defeated
well we are rumored that it's not quite
bednar there may be more
moves more activity from that direction
could you update us on that uh...
yes i think i can as a matter of fact
last week when i was taking elevator up
to date
house chambers i have the right with
carl vincent the chairman of the armed
services committee
that time he
told me quite
off the record that uh...
he felt that he would be out with a new
you mt bill which would be so modified
that even i could go for
you had a lag time in that i doubt that
very much because as long as there is
any of that all you empty they all come
up with the package
no matter how much cellophane and think
we have a make without i'm afraid i
can't buy that kind of a problem
well but you know that they are working
just dropped her opposition to the all
you want to do with ministration you
want to go
or is there a lot of points there mister
rogers the first place is terribly
expensive the first year will cost over
format and wanted billion dollars in
after that it'll cost over two billion
dollars a year
a trillion dollars land
the first year would be the first year
to the fact of course uh...
mister bentsen somewhat the cat out of
the baggage to the extent he was willing
to go in compromise
when he introduced his amendment on the
floor of the house to make you empty
not effective until nineteen fifty five
but the expenses a
terrible factor
that uh... one ten two billion dollars
for instance amounts to more money
than it cost to send all the young men
and women in the united states to go
through college or university to scope
romance in that sense of that is just a
bit for our audience that
many of whom have uh... a young sons
now is it true today sir that every
uh... man approaching ever eighteen
every young american
must anticipate that you have to search
sometime in military training
i think you're absolutely right mister
hewitt goes right now the draft
just taking all the available and we're
going to have whether we call a grant to
the u_n_ geo whatever we call it
uh... every able-bodied young man has to
uh... pay some sort of military training
and estimate right
and uh... so the cave your argument the
argument is over
type of military training is going to
get it out his exact you're not opposed
to universal military training on august
approach to the bill or notify issue i
think it's very clear about the issue
was that we have to find something
of getting done better reservists to
replace
the federal reserve that's underway now
depends but before we get to that point
sent everyman must face it and there are
two plans now for everyone is big
government plan
uh... which is uh... demand or hoop
by mister bentsen
are advocated that mister bentsen
chairman of the house armed services
committee
the other is your plan of the plan
that's been a while value any group of
freshmen congressmen in the house and
that is right that's right
now that power what are the major
differences between the government plan
and the plan advocated
back beyond batted freshman congressman
i might put it this way r_o_t_c_
evolutionary more use of the
revolutionary war taking the high school
r_o_t_c_ playful fraud
which has existed now for many many
years in which a lot of pain sixty two
thousand youngsters italian-american
down the line that plan would take
all u_n_ mandates cooper trying to take
them away from home that is not
your plan any envisions
keeping them at home intimate home where
they're subjected to their home
environment and the influences of
aldrich ames were big admiral
uh... military training and opposed to a
regular military going out of all mister
others because after their
to senior years of high school the
junior and senior year
they are then taken to wait six weeks
summer camp where they receive
training in the particular branch of the
service
which they have chosen order which
they've been the stuff and presumably
they will also receive praise orders
saying that site everybody not as benign
as r_o_t_c_ jordan
all right now your plan first would keep
them at home or that is not what is the
second advantage that you've taken
advantage if we do not interrupt his
educational progress are playing fits
into a summer vacation and his normal
high school instruction
young man is going to take a long
technical question college isn't faced
with the possibility of having to
extended education another year
because of you and i believe mister
bentsen is the government spokesman has
called your plan they tend the garden
plant
is that fair criticism
no i don't think so because of my plan
with the kindergarten friend mister
benson and his committee on armed
services of engaging in a lot of
give a damn activity for several years
because they have had
high school r_o_t_c_
almost since the national defense act of
nineteen seventeen
authorized
and has he has to r_o_t_c_ plan been at
call successful by the military and it
worked very well several of the
executives on reserve affairs and stated
that many of the non-commissioned
officers in the early and critical days
of world war two and many of the
aviation flying today
where young men would receive their
first military training in high school
r_o_t_c_
and who jumped out ahead of the group
as a result of that fact that how you
want to keep them at home sir and your
also worked as a congressman
you've been investigating military
expenditures
night with your plan
uh... be less expensive for the taxpayer
than the plan advocated by the
government we estimate that it'll only
cost about fifteen percent asthma
friends and just to give you an example
of what's happening right now
school and college the department of
defense
is able to state that they are training
two hundred and two thousand
one hundred and forty-one
high school and college r_o_t_c_ steam
for a total cost of twenty million
dollars
that includes all the instructors
equipment that type of thing
out-of-pocket expenses actually running
eleven dollars and fifty six cents
of pc year are and that's not content of
the water
campus to do the two billion one hundred
million dollars
which it will cost complain the trainees
under the administration plan
which calls for one instructor
orange to running for student measures
eleven dollars and fifty six cents per
student
at that level
fifty-six lots about a hundred dollars
that comes out of the twenty million yes
right now what we're doing u_n_ three
the administration u_n_ people have
already made with about twenty eight
hundred dollars ukraine one student for
six months which i think it's a little
high because i understand you can go to
harvard or yale for eighteen or nineteen
hundred dollars
for our school year nine operably in
such a
now it could cost twenty eight hundred
dollars six
for the government to train once
young man for six months that is what
and it cost eighteen hundred dollars for
a young man to go to harvard toward nine
months
and uh... you you think that that's too
much money i think something ever
and i think there's a lot of empire
building in there a lot of new commands
will be created and and a lot of
extra stamps in a lot of high command
you contend that the military training
the child murderer you can grow much
i'll be on managed to restrain
under your program will be comparable or
as who it is a military training you
need to know that we do it is that the
basic training which is the only thing
congress ever authorized in public law
fifty one which is the basic legislation
minus four-point notorious ecole
branching material every lead me in fact
daddy i have a camera edit out as a
matter of fact this holstein grew up
through art
that if you can take a young man and
give him for years
of college r_o_t_c_
six weeks of summer camp
information into the second lieutenant
to leave men and come back
you could certainly make a product
out of a young man in the last two years
of high school
with a six-week summer camp it has
worked in the past that i can see where
it is my second lieutenants in seventeen
weeks
that's right
athletic dublin's i might add
that congressman that you and your
colleagues
our freshman
congressman yes and now you're
challenging some of these oldtimers
who've been on the armed services
committee for thirty years
now what is it in your background that
lead you to think that you might be an
expert in this field letter thank them
very humble about that whole thing is to
put it back in thirty mins depart
bentsen came into the congress today i
was born
we offer this plant to the armed
services committee for their study
we offer this plan to the american
legion for stuff
we have tried to work
with all of these groups that exist as
far as we possibly can
what we are very proud that the
common-sense practical approach of our
plan
make it successfully and carrying the
football than the telephone on the floor
of the house of representatives
meeting of the committee about have you
had training as a psychologist
if i have my college work is in
psychology as a matter of fact i was a
personnel consultant on military duty
and in the end of my five years service
in world war two
all of us who drafted this plane you see
have seen this thing
that from the standpoint of the boys
with the stars
and the boys with the white gold on the
cows
well about the ban on the other side
training them and being trained
when we think that we have been having
perspective
by a margin of justice committee is
composed of a majority of nombre
now she would like uh... finally we'd
like you to give us your prediction as
to what will happen in this struggle
between the two systems the government
and the one in which you're advocating
or my prediction the
that the american people
avenue
evidence indicating that this we have
never had a flood of mail such as we had
a new empty
at the american people
one american planet you empty instead of
the european a genetically lam
all they've got to do is not their own
congressman mel
and he's sitting down there waiting in
washington
waiting to hear from them if you do what
they want
because
in the wonderful american tradition
this is an election year
thank you mister branson ensure that our
audience's appreciate your views thank
you for being with us
the editorial board for this edition of
the mounting problems go plugs
mister william bradford healy and mr
donald araki
our distinguished guests was the
honorable charles b bombs them
united states representative from india
problem afflicting a gift of great press
these towards someone important
that problem is most apple itself with
laundry
the world's most on at once
because of the outstanding quality of
the watch itself
and because of what the name long xem
stand
through the whole world
long-chain fans as they only walk in
history when the blast of all the ward
thirty eight times at world square as an
international exposition
including ten grand prize
twenty eight gold medal
protein also found for the water first
choice
aviation science and other fields of
precise timing
non gene stands for the only watch
could be classified for it
at the four great government observatory
washington
geneva q paddington and no shutdown
fifties broadening important occasion
is laundry
the world's most on at once
and throughout the world no other name
on a walk mean so much
and yet you made by and on
are by and probably give them on chemo
for as little as seventy one bit
long-chain the world's most on it well
premium product of the long game but not
locked up
since they came sixty six
maker of watches of the highest gap
we invited to join if every monday when
the day on friday evening at the same
time
or the lobbying crossfit
the television journal of the important
because of the hour
broadcast on behalf of launching the
world's most on iraq
and whatnot distinguished companion to
the world all night long g
this is frank night
reminding you of that loan demand with
no boxes
uh... sold and service from coast to
coast
by more than four thousand leading to
other
who proudly display this emblem
agency logon jeanerette norwalk
the laurel along artwork walk walk the
dog walking
on june watches that one can wear a
program prices twenty eight gold medals
and more on this for accuracy than any
other time these
won't do the world's most honored
watchers made and guaranteed by the
wanted what more watch company
times on the lawn games on it
television journal of the important in
terms of the aisle
talk show you every monday wednesday and
friday
the president and dean witter na wat tam
later on
laundry the world's most on it wont
and what
not distinguished companion to the world
on it laundry
good evening
this is frank night
marion produce our characters for this
edition of the loan gene com usko
mr donald i roger as an editor of new
york never could be on and mister victor
is out of the new york daily merit
our distinguished guest for this evening
is the owner of a christian ahe tar
united states congressman from
massachusetts
the opinions expressed are necessarily
those of the speaker
congressman hunter
audience those of you as a member of the
house foreign affairs committee
and as a leading republican congress
uh... i wonder if you speak to a certain
might have been about the foreign
affairs of our nation i think perhaps
the most
pressing foreign problem or
perhaps most
popped up one problem
is whether or not you know i've been run
for president
the republican party
whether obviously i've got to express
our opinion
i happen to be a great deal yet the for
general eisenhower
as a candidate for the on the republican
ticket
and my feeling about the devil
and very briefly briefing by the fact
that i think you've got concept
the important
overall foreign relations
today
in unequal but many people in public
life
i have a very deep conviction
that all foreign relations
condition
almost everything that happened in our
domestic affairs
and in other words of today
the conduct of our product a is the most
important
in our domestic life welcome king
hussein the general has concept
well he has been asked by virtually
everybody what most concepts are
uh... he's not declaring at least can
you tell us what he stands for on on
foreign problems in on domestic problems
and becomes president around this
country
what does general eisenhower spin
for over truth elder obviously i'm a
physician we have a private room
i think will be published work
i could tell you that i've talked to him
own individual and commit myself
the league of extraordinary clear
oprah
our role
in that world
if condition by the relationship with
all the other countries
nobody
compete for it
you cannot speak for themselves what
will happen to them
well i'm convinced of that will come and
go through that live in conference
become available in february
that that is the time where you've got
to make
at least his electability
of the commander in chief in europe
feltham
speaking without power
i'm getting but i think it will come
very from their right political
significance in the united states any
political events
which might
hastens decision of declaring himself
will remember fingerprint happening
automatically
you know a political life
remove hampshire
promo on the ten th
when the new hampshire more
at the end of january the twentieth of
january to be exact
the sector statement if you have got to
notify any potential candidates
whose name they go about
right now of course that may go on the
ballot
in america
lived here ten days in which to avoid
name from developing hissy fit the
development of the democrats of the
sample rod
though the favor of it
and i think it directly to the game
the road to recovery primary believed
everything go on the republican vote
i really believe that we can offer them
at all
well congo
make him a conjecture and obviously are
convinced he can stand for the
presidency the united states if you can
get the republican nomination
even if you can get the nomination if he
declares
referred to
i think even headgear
and even had to get the michael barone
political power and control
there were a little bit of a goodly
critical of that like to talk about
is this for me
or owned productive capacity of the
country than carrying out
that could be used in the setting up the
european army how does this affect
general
effect agreement for the whole time
schedule
barbecue were supposed to operate from
the point of view are unified command
on the on the eve of a minimal number of
vision
preventive way back bar all before
making further intervention that uh...
isn't this prime what happened to the to
line up
they probably have not been to him
the time i got it refused to do it
i think you'll find when you have a live
picture at the time that you could do
perfectionists
in the military felt who've not been
satisfied with family
give-and-take and he couldn't play any
given government would want to make
about one until they've never given firm
order
to turn up something were to be sent to
your or simply but your honor walkabout
hillary close at hand and asked for the
russians keep producing better tanks
transplanting complains that my brother
keep producing
careerbuilder unfortunately have been
doing a good deal
with a perfectionist designs but we
wanted to know
la cell phone and blueprints on
for that reason i think with big ten
months till you get a behind what we
should have been from the point of view
of the appropriation to congressman will
come sooner than you think that the
uh... another planet reorganization as a
failure uh...
no you say it has more on that
loughborough road trip
we're not allowed to carry on with it
for a long way to go
when you're putting together
the armed forces over brickman
deformation under a unified command
you've got on tremendous number of
problems dealing with national pride
national sovereignty
haley
schedules of the different
non-commissioned officer of the authors
of everything that we connected
making a unified whole
of a conglomerate where of different
nationalities well that brings up the
carnival or royal
method churchill says that he will the
throwin
with us and an eighty l
if we keep mister general eisenhower the
command of the european operation
uh... which sort of puts mister
churchill on the role of supporting pat
no doesn't teach britain out of the
general declares izzy
going to declare is he going to stay in
the church who come in
if he goes out
well i think i think that there are no
or have absorbed in the uh... iffy
question
i don't think that uh...
though to bring the deficit related
in our i think that there was no could
get
brief picture
such a
that he can very probably
workout
omit a competent
successor carryout
and then we'll talk about the bought the
individual with your feet
attorney put on the defective
organizationally don't believe for
constant that's not a iffy question
uh... when prime minister at the british
empire winston churchill the very
determined and he said he doesn't go
ahead and include general goes out now
uh... general made it clear about what
happens to the not liking organization
england doesn't come through
could do it better to do it to be
tie me over the story of a man
thank you so they'll go ahead
should do a good way to get to go on the
network followed by a very succinct
statement attributed to draw the
the almond
problem in europe on the relationship of
a unified europe
that i have a feeling that the second
favorite completely overshadowed the
third
above the fold dealing with the
inevitability of either or many of the
picture
recovered to proceed
masters uh...
if the gel runs i don't think this
question is i've yet than that
of what will you run with your high on
the republican rights
your booming eisenhower president and
you people considered
and running mate to generalize
well rather make better use of the need
to be considered proforma
the convention
times two oh six months away
primary consideration
you're getting to know about it with
them
you have some kind of that
well i better about that
but could you build certain factors
today that are working again tonight
with peter and i thought
minimizing which is awesome
today
will be careful to develop
yesterday
that uh... undermining people safe
in the administration's ability to carry
on
and on it
administration and the character problem
in allot of veritable purple-topped vial
all other forms of government
burger growing conviction that the
republicans could win with an e ticket
workflow
a dangerous supposition
i mean for the republican but with the
kids i think we've been doing a good
thing
illusion if you will recall that
before andover i don't want to have to
really get invite any candidate you mean
subject
well i think that uh... i will never be
the best of individual
of the puzzle could have been for thirty
years
but some that uh... to find an
individual who from the point of view
ordinary rules of the game
would be entitled innovation foreign
contribution to the book you can't even
mention
if not i
principal we've got to go forward about
i had no many people in hopes of birth
here i think that he can win
time that we have a very much better
chance of winning america get program or
reported to the future of the country
o'connor's matter we certainly
appreciate you coming with us
i do have
unlike nelson who do you know about
general eisenhower's chances campaign we
appreciate you being with us tonight
the editorial board for this edition of
the laundry thomasville flaws
mr donald i rogers
and mister victories o
our distinguished guests was the
honorable christian paying her care
united states congressman from
massachusetts
the worldwide prestige of launching
watches as proof of their unsurpassed
dependability and accuracy
these qualities of the result of the
extraordinary excellence
ended diane and the manufacturer of the
long gene watch
the beating heart
every lawn jamar
here is the mature product
of the skill
and experience
acquired through eighty five years of
watch me
the opera slow-motion camera reveals
this move
faultless mechanism of the launching
balance assembly
the guardians of the accuracy of the
watch
through his magnifying glass
the skilled watch makers season
additional
the pressures hand finishing of the
central park
which makes them on gene wants so
superior
so out
yes there are plenty of the reasons why
long g_m_ watchers have one ten world's
fair brown prizes
twenty eight gold medal
and so many hours for a cure asean feels
of precise timing
when next you buy a while
for yourself or does it get
remember
if you pay seventy one fifty or more for
a while
not paying the price of a long journey
and you should insist on getting along g
the world's most artbox
premium product
for the long she might not want to
company
since eighteen sixty six
maker of watches all of the hired him
business frank night again reminding you
that the modine com usko
is brought to you three times weekly
every monday wednesday and friday
so what you're doing this every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time
along gene promised
a television journal of the important
people whom they are
broadcast
them hahaha of logging
roll's most all day long
and whatnot
distinguished companions of the world
all night long journey
sold and service from coast to coast
by more than four thousand leading to a
proudly displayed the emblem
agents a hold on teamwork
off ballgames
doesn't make it on t_v_ that's not what
hero logging world most armored car
handbook
distinctly from handfuls of or about
fleas detroit's
let u self-awareness is for this edition
of the boxing props
mister contract with the way
atmospherics that whatever management
editor of business week magazine
our distinguished guests will concede
you honorable separate
buttonface representative prompter
cationic
here's for state your and congressman
calmer
call eight eighty
came for for it
fifty
a part of operation condor
case
asset anxious
first
installed the stork
can fight before
supports and more
is impressive
certainly nothing like this has happened
there
dress twenty years did you get verse
educations
flight our guests
i think that something like two hundred
forty-five people
consist of oracle
by the special category like hugh
scrutton
most of the rest
our people are going
you into the new administration given
that
everybody mills
didn't want it
before it
tell i'll
streamer your job
money make
who will pop a popular elspeth
them all for it but that sure though
will be
we have activity
is quarters
there is no any federal appropriation
for and it's an expensive thing to have
fifty-five ones now
pulitzer
on various possibilities seems to me and
ought to be explored
i'm not sure that i can see quickly any
reason why they should be such a long
delay between election day in the
moderation day
the purpose of course corporations to
make this transition from one of the
mystery should motorist whose possible
without unlike how much operation
weekly cost
instruction preached
post lectins named additional
people do this to happen at company
headquarters in treatment for duties
uh... right now are expected something
neighborhood of twenty five thousand
dollars a week
and how are you plant
considerable about
exactly what it
has been raised just by pete wilson in
subscription to
contributions uh... moringa
organizations in existence and any
possible ground for criticism
x
it seems to me
there is no profit though i'm not
certain suggestion but option
hill with that being imported
plot richmond your call
something st
uh... point
spot
specialist pineapples beauty mikey d_
cast
i want to say what
but this is
cumbersome scott's position too
has not been that
son left with after all but the
administration
we are there
ridding it has to be done to which it or
experience unit is holed up
first few most
iced
it's going to work out
every confidence that uh...
there will be a complete
completely harmonious operation between
gender checking and congressman jim
cotton obscured
secure
think you can
this experience
it wave
apparently can get our viewers
advocates work to expect
from still moves on down to washington
flooding
how seriously sick
came from
big first few weeks
desensitizing requested for small
has been a very dramatic
happening extend over the period
beginning her
eight thirty on
election day
and continuing right on down through the
content
fittings
dramatic specter
uh... i don't think that uh...
shortening the in the world this is
going to be across this picture
solid
war if you're a
if t zz s
continue station be repealed
work
throughout i'm sure that adventure quest
implanted nothing happened
dope
the deepest cuts it
we are going to get one free and it
sooner than would otherwise text will
come down sooner than otherwise they
would
some legislative programs are going to
be
who've been carried out without further
but i don't love
himself because i think you need
locations
undoubtedly wants
the fetus
comp washington are bookclub will be
going washington
obviously their organization you
expressed government
uh... well uh... improved
you can save money the government
operation
i'm through that the administration
will do that
which include a
leaders from business in north america
putting in his cabinet and since they
should
great health
house speaker of the
break
that'd be important to be a coterie of
people behind the scenes were running
the show
i couldn't do it
there were such under
i knew about it
i wouldn't be able to see itself as a
matter of fact
i don't believe there it's that kind of
thing and abstract sir front
consists
been building you something new
he
most people
most americans
aston shizzle
and happened since nineteen thirty
or can you
reviewed
what's the difference is going to be
here
we've had for the first
lisa markups yours
the administration's moving down
mr smith
waited it's she made
factor that's been in office so long has
been getting slower and slower grinding
tool
we know
coming into office and twenty two
january
chris presence by the
public and congress which to focus by
saturday
an administration is fresh and comes
with vigor
none of the handicap for the barnacles
attached field
complete dedication
single perk
doing the best
foreign affairs and in domestic affairs
and on time
part of the greatest profits at the
results
which are expected
some people think
theorized martin streets pace perhaps
nineteen fifty three is a uh...
feverish
how you have uh... sent her campaign
speaks relaxed
that the republican party because
there's nothing to worry
the uh...
the title of the year
depression party
difference towards the general public
will they moved the quickly
if there is
an incentive that sort
i'm sure the administration or proper
matchbox which report
i was talking about the repetition
rather than in actuality
something that
successfully posted on that sir
for certain branches of the forty
many people's minds
i was born in europe
we should not accept
and and must not and i'm sure we agreed
we will not do anything to do
score
the repeats
you politician
and in very limited
house your date
you
about life
mind a lot of pork barrel district in
the next
we have no great public works with our
desire to be on the part of their
camelot
with wants
or that this is not saying that it's got
to put it wants to have good solid
representation
stoop
hobs underside of the tampa
let
themselves that was a little discussion
the specific late desperate
street you're going to be off
it was good
i don't believe anybody
the collective turned down
but before we thought it was all for
before i think it's
question sir
texans
administration is going to be week
on politician
business
care
spirit politicians
going to be shortened to politicians
the invites
both indeed
ministrations jic you saw it
and of course in congress where we have
experienced politicians men from way
back from all the trade
off haha im sure
the
we will have no difficulty
vivica softness in the fall
thank you very much place
if it is you could always because the
first night are i do
editorial board for this edition of the
mounting public school fourth mister
william bradford your week
mr richard what they have managed to get
into a business week magazine
of distinguished guests with the
honorable statistics united states
representative from each other
discriminating people will go over the
find in launching the qualities that you
see fit a thirty five one
resurrection sequence
novelette lobbied watches enough
celebratory activity competitions did
not accept
over these years
smoking what business ethics committee
work
one promptness awards for individual
watches
and series of what is in the greater
service boards
manchester
do you think
and of course wanting to be only
watching this
for wind whilst at grand prizes
forty-eight food network
if you have to work interested to know
what superior quality
either for you and so forth an important
tips
you'll choose where
virtues launching
the world's most armored hua
for what do you want to talk with you
explosives dot
impressive appeared
great directors
and reassurance
apa long long block
if you made by boom
off probably if we're going to watch
forthwith let's set
you want it
lockheed the world's most powerful
the world's most politics
for your call
flogging but not what happened
simply sixty six
maker what is at the highest death
invited to join
automotive cancel
television girl looking for pieces of
the hour
booked asap apple laundry
the world's most popular walk
which people
six-feet companion
for the world almost launching
this is david lewis
remind you of this multi whitmore
watches
foxholes and circus club coast to coast
five more than four thousand leader to
others
will probably be slated seven
agencies velocity with normal
time for the logging promised us
television journal of the important
things to build it out
haha you every monday wednesday and
friday
a presentation of the laundry let's
throw up
later on
launching the world's most ahmed walk
and whatnot distinguished companion to
the world on and on gene
believing that this frank not
may i introduce octal editors for this
edition of the mounting koshto
mister william bradford killing editor
of the american mercury
and mister hennelly has let contributing
editor of newsweek magazine
our distinguished guest for this evening
is mister fact of the roosevelt junior
united states represented the from new
york
mister roosevelt were very happy to
welcome you to the classical program
this evening
i'd like to begin by asking you what you
thought of the charges that
senator mccarthy made against uh...
governor stevenson
must add that first of all my express my
gratitude for your inviting me here
tonight
as for the mccarthy speech tonight high
unfortunately was not able to see
here all of it ided get the last part of
it where
uh... the senator from wisconsin was
once again
uh... bringing in the affidavit
governor stevenson made in me his trial
in which of course
governor stevenson
testified in writing by his affidavit
only to the fact that when he noticed in
the state department
test-ban had a reputation egg would
reputation in the community
that was all
but some of them a copy as usual
uh... tried to read much more into it
now what do you think that uh...
governor stevenson showed good judgment
in making that deposition
i think that as an attorney come as a
citizen
uh... in our
procedure of justice in the courts i he
hath had an obligation
to state what he knew
the reputation
his had in the community at that time
it was not his
opinion of his his reputation it was his
a opinion on the reputation his hat in
the community at that time for granted
that day he had to do you speak if he
thought that a_t_f_ perjurer was a loyal
citizens
uh... did it show good judgment and
thinking that will of course how he had
not been convicted of perjury at the
time
governor stevenson made that uh...
affidavit
and that was the decision of the jury
after the his trial road and i think
that this trial as a hung jury when you
think it would show that governor
stevenson who can tell a communist when
he sees one so to speak
no i don't think it shows that at all
yes
but my copy would like him his job
on the cut this feature
uh... do you think that it might be
affected
for the republicans we're not having
read the whole speech i can't say i
don't think that mccarthy is affected
for the republicans
for one very simple reason
but i think the american people
realized that mccarthy
crucified the character and reputation
without evidence of too many
and secondly that not one single person
has been convicted as a result of mister
mccarthy's efforts
removing justice department at the same
time
has convicted thirty-three
well-known communist leaders
moving on to the to the campaign sir
uh... i'd believe it
you at least made one favorable
statement about general asking howard
nineteen forty eight
that you march of nineteen forty eight
i_d_
did make a statement saying that i felt
that general eisenhower could unify the
country
no i surrender landed here enthusiasts
and began to
leg for general eisenhower within the
three weeks that followed that statement
i discovered
the impressions that i have a very uh...
generalizing house position on the
issues a could not be verified and the
general eisenhower did not go
uh... would express himself on the
issues nor was he attended one of those
impressions come from mister
that was nineteen forty eight i'd say
that they probably were general idea
the people have about the fact that
eisenhower at that time ah... certainly
was a very humane in the great military
leader
and uh... certainly was highly respected
both here in the and throughout the
world i think he's still is respected
and that my it was a great military
leader when they're about the campaign
that the democrats have waged against
general eisenhower
do you feel sure that uh... any of the
charges leveled at and have been unfair
well i uh... haven't documented all the
charges that have been leveled against
him i've been pretty busy being
positive in this campaign on behalf of
governor stevenson of course my own
reelection
i'd say that
uh... the
main charge against general eisenhower
has been
not that he has failed to repudiate
mccarthy jenna
who crucified uh... his own great right
hero general marshall
about that he has positively albany dos
these people
the very essence of the old guard
republicans
and i think that the charge that he is
now a captive of the old guard is
unjustified shop
i think that could be strong by his
acceptance also had to pass
prepared statement
prepared in cincinnati and he brought up
to uh... columbia for his meeting with
eisenhower
and eisenhower except
was a sport greg crime for mister
eisenhower who was running on a
republican ticket
to be supporting so to speak the views
of mister republican
well uh... he uh... he conquered mister
republican in chicago and then was
conquered by mister republican at
columbia university i don't think it's a
crime of course not
is that this is a free country
i don't think it will help him though
with the american people because i don't
think that some of the path
is a wha
he was nominated by the republicans are
those leaving other problems or took
questions on president truman
in the first place ur do you think that
truman's tactics have been on fairness
campaign i think that uh...
it's hard to say that they're unfair for
the simple reason that we know harry
truman is a tough fight or in any
campaign
that's how he won the election in
nineteen forty eight
i think that some of the things he has
said
have hurt some people
their sensitivities on the other hand i
think he is arouse the democratic party
and i think that is uh... campaigning
has been helpful land where i was not
like to ask this
question whether that is the primary
sort of double standard
now while i can to say about senator
mccarthy he's a tough fighter and he's
been effective
uh... why is it alright i don't know how
you are at truman well reliable on this
new while you apply what seems to me a
double standard of uh... of uh... in
orlando
how about the in a land of adverse to
truman made
that uh... general eisenhower was anti
semitic an anti catholic he did not know
when he did not say that
we may be and when do i know what he
said was that
and actually didn't even deliver the
speech himself although he approved the
speech what he said was
that general eisenhower
was now endorsing positively
those men who had past and supported
the mccowan bail which it is
selective in any racial mister roseanne
annie police chiefs and the italian it's
an eastern european and so forth
governor stevenson has been repudiating
any of the candidates who would be
democratic candidates are favored the
death of a difference between
repudiation handing dawson
that's all up to one set
eisenhower's one out of his way to
endorse these cannibal has mister
stevenson and or some of the people who
voted for the karen act
the democrats
i don't know i don't uh... no below or
governor stevenson has endorsed anybody
yes hasn't been heralded such as the
endorsements as a carpetbagger
roosevelt unfair that our viewers want
to know something about you and your own
campaign see after all you represent one
of the big westside districts in new
york city
how has your own has your own campaign
going what i've been spending five days
a week
four or five meetings night
meeting with my constituents discussing
the issues with
i have a very instant district it's a
very independent this trip
i'd say that it is liberal it's
progressive
because i hope they uh... reelect me to
congress well and one on a four freedoms
and
platform ginger the first time around i
i i ran on the liberal party head of the
state of the also the independent four
freedoms party fundraiser traditionally
democratic uh...
constituency if not say that it's
traditionally department
uh... enacted in nineteen forty nine
elected me i was not
the democratic candidate
then they voted for mentality re
quite overwhelmingly when he ran as an
independent nineteen fifty
they voted for mister howie when he ran
as an independent liberal party
candidate in nineteen fifty one
and that one other question about the
family certainly that uh...
one of your brother's supporting general
eisenhower analysis on usual at play
defection in the roosevelt family like
there's no i i don't think it's
particularly unusual we practice what we
pay to me at roswell family we believe
in freedom of speech
freedom of thought
in the right of every whim to express
himself really
eddie fields called upon to do so i
frankly though i don't think jerry stern
influence of the votes i don't think i
have but i think my mother is
what are your mother taking an active
part in the last few days at a campaign
to certainly issues into this and
governor stevenson through the madison
square garden rally tomorrow night and
as as a final question mister roosevelt
uh... do you expect any
dramatic mood
this in the last part of the campaign
no i don't look for any dramatic most
uh... i think the general eisenhower's
shot is what we decide to go to korea
personally
what he'd do when i got that he didn't
say
i think that the american people will
vote to continue the prosperity of the
democrats and continue
the hope for peace in the world
through the united nations the point
four program nato well thank you sir for
being with us thank you
the opinions that you've heard our
speakers expressed tonight
our entire they they are
the editorial board for this edition of
the launching promise go
laws mister william bradford killing
and mister henry hudson
our distinguished guests was mr franklin
d_ roswell junior united states
represented the from new york
during the past weeks for the words of
some of our speakers spoken during the
heat of the political campaign have
about considerable comment
an occasional
out this time the logging but not watch
company puts aside it usual commercial
message to give our method as an
opportunity to explain to you the policy
of the launching products co
for this purpose we present
mister william bradford gilly
as a magazine edit that out there
once a year activate policy statement to
the readers
tonight as unedited abhi khana scope
i'll give a policy statement
launching quick dog again this
program
on it once a week basis and now for more
than a year we've operated three times a
week
uh... over a very large nation wide
network
and we are pleased that
so many have you have like the program
now here's what we do
regardless of political persuasion
we bring the most important people in
america right into your living room
we seek them comfortably
and then they forthright but
friendly manner we asking the questions
that we think that you have like the
rams
and in doing this we take a risk
hazardous business
of bringing ah...
uh... guest into other people's living
room
and sometimes when we bring a rather
controversial character on one side of
the other
are you don't like it
and a great many argue
protest
that when this happens
we are sorry
quite honestly what can we do
neither i nor the sponsors of the
network
exercise any control over what to say it
we are not censor
we have to take the risk
u_n_ ag
free speech
we ask the questions
you take the risks forget what answers
you've yet
then two we had it is our
are often criticized because
we don't hurry up into some guests
because we don't try to refute what he
has to say are too embarrassing
and i particularly uh... get criticized
because as a writer i have some
reputation as a referee
but here we don't do any ripping we
don't smile shinning equals
and we are quite proud of the fact that
in all our programs we've never had a
guest you went away thinking that he'd
been treated unfairly
so during our second year we expect to
bring you stimulating kal optically view
from the most active men and women in
the world
you examine them
you look into their eyes on these big tv
close-ups and you decide what you think
about them
now that's our policy
we invite you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time for the logging pronto
the television journal of the important
issue who they are
broadcast on the top of launching in the
world's most honored watch
and whatnot distinguished companion to
the world dot i dot e
this despite not reminding you that
logging on what no what
household in service from coast to coast
by more than four thousand leading to a
who proudly displayed at them
agency bogging when norwalk
gained momentum
television journal of the important in
terms of the hour
talk show you every monday wednesday and
friday
a presentation of the laundry much more
about company
maker on montagne the world's most ahmed
walk
and what
distinguished companion to the world on
and on gene
good evening that the fact that
managers are co-editors for this edition
of the mounting calls go
mister williams that they're doing
editor of the american market
and mostly doctor stillman associate
our distinguished guests for this
evening is they are both with regard to
their junior united states congressman
from new york
the opinions expressed are necessarily
those of the speaker
this today rollins of course knows that
you are a
distinguished and veteran member of the
congress of the united states
and tonight uh... sense there's a lot of
interest in the presidential campaign
uh... some of our audience uh... i'm
sure would like to know something of the
problems of the four hundred and
thirty-five congressman
who are running for reelection
now you of course is standing for
reelection in your district united have
at least quite bright
and i know you're a
for europe
terminal b that is i've completing a
third term in running for the fourth
then that's quite right
and what is your district
the seventeen th
district of new york the ground up and
down the middle of manhattan on the east
side largely in part of a grunge
straight through to the east river from
fifth avenue and it goes down uh...
below washington square now is that no
one is one of the silk stocking district
in new york
it was known as a silk stocking district
when people were silk stockings but
nobody where stockings anymore so i
think possibly that's not what you say
it's a typical district and and uh...
the metropolitan area i think it's a bad
cross sec
sin of the population of
manhattan
was a good beer do you think that uh...
not with mister eisenhower having been
there
nominated as the republican presidential
candidate your chances for your home
rewrite
have improved
well i have very little about
you do that with a ticket that we've got
now headed by uh...
general eisenhower
and my former colleague of my house
senate annexin
uh... that we're going to end i'm quite
sure that
in my own district the republicans will
carry officers from the president down
you're a republican do you think that
uh... general eisenhower's
proving himself to be a good campaigner
common i think he started off in great
shape
i think the exchange between me
president and the general uh... the last
twenty four hours about the invitation
to
uh... visit the white house and put the
truman with
yelp around his neck at the start the
right much to the credit of the general
charlie was very much on the job and
very alert to the issue
you you don't uh... believed and have
some critics who charge that uh...
general eisenhower or may not
debbie that type of man who can make the
case against the democratic party
by no means i think you make the most of
it and i think you should buy the
effective leadership i think we're going
to have a prime smashing campaign that's
going to result in victory myself and
you think that uh...
that most of the uh...
of the republican
uh... members of congress
who are carrying on their campaigns in
their own distinct
that they are satisfied with the
national ticket and help that they will
get from the national ticket
as far as i've been in contact with them
yes of course i can speak for all the
four hundred and thirty-five
when i or
new york state it forces
pivotal state in this election
and there's a great deal of conjecture
as to how
the state will go
our nineteen forty eight of the the
state uh... went for governor
but uh... that was largely because uh...
or may have been because mister
wallace's running involved a large bowl
now this year with an update their
decade in the
in the picture
how do you think new york state likely
to go
well obviously it will be a good deal
more difficult to carry new york without
help of a split
in the opposition
but i think here
all of our republicans are going to
stand firmly together
uh... i think they're going to make this
fight without reservation
i think the issues are very great very
important
i'm personally it
confident that the people of new york we
appreciate the issues sufficiently uh...
to throw out the democratic
administration in washington and the
like
generalizing one out of the uh... the
the various
boarding groups and new york
do you think the general eisenhower
pulled will run strong among the
labor groups the the you'd labor union
groups in new york state
my own impression
that there was a very large element
among the
so-called label i hope that will vote
republican
they bartered republican before
and not so long ago hope you'll remember
great men in a much devoted to bob that
development when he was re-elected
and i think that tax conscious and i
think that conscious of inflation and i
think a great many of
so-called livable
will support the republican ticket
mister could build and there have been a
lot of talk about the so-called negro
who what do you think about the negro
called new york state
because i can only
yes like i can only speak for the negro
vote new york state
uh... my own impressions varied and
uh...
based upon my knowledge of that
eisenhower going to get a great deal of
support i think from the negro home and
rightly so
because it's new york state after all
that was a fine here in the end of
discrimination acts
i think the new york legislature was the
first
state legislature to pass the act
and i think uh...
many of our new york negro to realize
that
thus far more chances of achieving their
aspirations and objectives
uh... under a republican administration
in washington and under a democratic
administered
let complected and to and column in your
own this picture
now uh... and leave the presidential
candidates are
arm into labor day to launch their
campaigns
are you waiting until labor day thing
dr campaign
no
no misty really i'm not i have been
campaigning unceasing late
since about
steve dave jewell ia and uh...
opposition
uh... petitions were filed in the
republican primaries so i have a primary
fight on my end first which comes to a
head on primary day on august nineteenth
and after that if enough republicans
come out the vote for me
i still have the
fight against
the democratic liberal party candidate
through to election day leveled out
uh... that's a very intersting situation
for our audience because you've actually
been out uh... rubbing shoulders and
shaking hands already with your
constituency
now uh...
what whatsoever but my
do you think your constituency here
loss during the next two to four years
if by that to mean wacom people thinking
about and the district
i would say the number one issue was
taxation
taxes are eating us alive all of us
one editorial in the daily news monday
and my impression is that the voters in
my district on very conscious of the
fact that taxes are giving them a lot
and that means spending and government
waste
and all of those with that i think
that's almost the number one issue
subject of course the warren buffet math
on now don't your people in your
district uh... think that this country
is enjoying great prosperity
i think they're great many of our people
our are are aware of the fact that their
son on official bombay shin on inflation
foundation and they're scared to death
of where it's going to leave
and they'd like to get down to a firearm
foundation balanced budgets
last public spending
and less
taxation
that's the kind of thing that means that
a solid
stable prosperity which is sort of the
future and
more than anything else
assures a future value of the dollar
that they save and then i'll make it
was prepared to move think that
after the election
republican party could win the election
it balanced budget will be possible you
think was the
on that person that we think that is
going on today that is really possible
to reduce taxes
and uh... work with the balanced budget
'cause that's a very big question but i
think there's a pretty
care answered philip
certainly there is a far greater threat
balancing the budget on a low level
and reducing taxers in a short time
with a republican administration with
eisenhower in the white house in
republican majorities in both houses
we'll get a much more prudent
financial management three lab
far less waste eleven barry will have no
corruption
and when you have
efficient management that found the main
large reductions twenty
and ultimately taxes within
the very near future
and i do say that your people are do you
think your people are most concerned
about the reduction of taxes
now is that because of some special
characteristics of your constituency
thanks a lot of heaven informers and i
don't happen to have a need
bombers
and i suppose perhaps it's because uh...
inner city district like mine
there are fewer people are getting
government handout
so that last conscious of the handout
aspect of government then the payee and
taxes aspect
your your constituents are home opinions
they're either playing out but i have a
very conscious of it and they don't like
it a bit
master
do you think this
do you think that they're likely to be
any surprises this year do you think
this is like to be an extraordinary
election year in which things that even
the political of seniors are low foresee
you think that end on november the fifth
nineteen fifty two that we elected a
wake up with some surprises
well i think governor stevenson the
democrats may have some sort
prizes
uh... it's my impression that there's a
very
seeded and
humid demand for a fundamental change in
washington
i think people are so anxious for a
change that they're not very to accept
any media change of pace that's a
tremendous teams
and they're going to
insist upon the kind of a change that
only comes with a change of party you
think that that perhaps is a large group
uh... in the center for instance
that may surprise uh... some of the
uh... people who are predicting the
election results that's my confident
hope
i think that's what's going to sleep
reelection
yesterday i'm sure that our
audience is very much appreciated your
views tonight thank you for being with
us and if you go in the common good
the editorial board for this edition of
the loans in costco
flows mister william bradford healy and
mister guenther through
our distinguished guests was the oliver
frederick a coup de junio united states
congressman from new york
to the true connoisseur of fine watches
no other name on a watch means so much
as long as he and the world's most part
one
such discriminating manned and women
appreciates the elegance of laundry
marches
the greater accuracy
and uh... faithful
worldwide acclaim
confirms that judgment
for among the world's fine watches
launching alone has one ten worlds where
grand prizes
twenty eight gold medal awards and
highest honors for accuracy from
government observatory
because the inherent accuracy and
dependability
sports encompass associations the world
over have made laundry and their oficial
while
for the call us are fine watches
no other name i watched means so much
has launching and yet the you know
but you may barn and probably well
ordeal
along gene walked
for as little as seventy one fifty
long jane the world's most on it well
premium product of the loan gene but
know what's company
since eighteen sixty six
maker of watches solve the highest debt
we invited to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time for the long jean pascoe
a television journal of the important
issues that we are
broadcast on behalf of laundry
the world's mohammed law
and whatnot distinguish companion to the
world on it launches
this is back nine
reminding you that laundry man with no
watches
are sold and service
from coast to coast
by more than four thousand leading to it
proudly display this end
agency follow on gene would not want
e door
all old honored offline honking
on june watches have one ten where a
program prices twenty eight gold medals
and more on this for accuracy than any
other time these
well into the world's most honored
watches maidan guaranteed by the wanted
what mom watch company
time for the laundry from it
television journal of the important
changes of the hour
partial you every monday wednesday and
friday
the presentation of the laundry mats na
wat tam
later on
laundry the world's most ahmed wat
and whatnot distinguished companion to
the world on its own gene
good evening
business pipeline
may i introduce our coletta for this
edition of the loan dean gonna still
rental and hotel that the minister of
the new york never tribune and mister
william bradford keighley
editor of the american mercury
our distinguished guests for this
evening is the honorable prep regard for
dad junior united states represented of
from europe
the opinions expressed
unnecessarily those of the speaker
mister command prompt reporting
many of them
remember reviewing inspired me
investigation of communist activity in
the new york skew
recently
and to keep you may know you're now has
a fighting member of the house
appropriations committee who is trying
to do something about what you think is
excessive government spending
and for many women still earn rather
sensational
resolution that you have recently
entities
now is the first question sir
wouldn't tell us first what this
resolution fears that you introduced in
congress
fundamentally
was furious resolution
provided
they always practical method
but i wish the people of this country
can affectively save themselves from
complete bankruptcy
and stop spending at a reasonable are
and that's a resolution to to halt
spending and to bring it to what you
call a reasonable level
master simply may have wanted to end it
the reasonable level low
that must be applied to the same level
of every household replied me don't
personal affairs limitation must be
available in co
unavailable involved in this case of
course
main who proceeded you know you probably
have a tax burden of the american people
are suffering under the day and i said
our government must not and cannot go on
spending more than the people are
willing and able to pay in taxes and
that's precisely what this
administration means to do unless we can
stop
mister cooper
uh... these are normal times
and i wonder
just tell look you propose would cut
into
proposed expenditures for the national
defense and for foreign aid
well obviously uh...
if any effect
needs to be made in the fantastic
performed with the president
to spend something like eighty five
billion dollars for three years in a row
there must be some reduction
uh... in the enormous request
military fund and some reduction in the
far end page report
the suggestion that there be such a
reduction in obviously not revolutionary
because my resolution
was specifically and expressly indoors
the time i announced it
by none other than former ambassador
mabus
united states ambassador to great
britain
was like many other men responsible for
the marshall plan
and responsible for the development of
the north atlantic treaty organization
dublin said to me in atlanta
that a seventy one limitation
the adhered to in order to save the
stubborn trade security agreements let's
let's before we keep the billion your
answer
most of those two months
don't know the difference between
seventy billions in eighty five billions
now i a you're telling us tonight that
our taxes he's very heavy taxes have
been living and i think the
bringing an about seventy one billion
june nineteen fifty two exact direction
that if the president own s
i see now and you can't do you believe
that we have reads
the wives limit for pizza and taxation
i happen to any doubt about it
but uh...
i don't ask you our listeners to rely
upon my opinion
side of the jordan chairman of the
finance committee in the senate a
democrat
and mister belton who's chairman of ways
names in the house which involved the
taxes and a great many others in the
congress and said we've reached the
limits are not going to be happening and
now you're saying that there is an
agreement between both republicans and
and democrats that seventy one billion
susie tax limit know that we can't go
above that agreement didn't exactly
where there's a recognition recognition
won't pay any recognition and the
president wants to spend eighty-five
billion dollar fort
dean billions more
and your resolution is designed to
prevent
then act how would your resolution
prevent this
it would impose
by congressional action any limitations
in seventy one million dollars of fun
spending
he would be
but that need to spend a dime more than
the seven b_ one band
out of the resolution passes
he would be required to submit within
thirty days a brand new biji
dividing up the seventy one million
these two five now is they're growing
support for your resolution
what what evidences of supportive you
fancy the most amazing evidences look
quite frankly
indicating perhaps the beginning of a
grassroots taxpayer's revolt back home
only today
kind of a more awesome oregon moment one
of them
great liberals on the republican side
demanded a fifth
being billion dollar reduction with
nineteen million out of foreign aid
and the military them
some of the probe and it's also a
democrat
uh... from illinois
a lot of the favorite liberals on the
democratic cell
uh... himself said the other day
that we ought to take at least four
billion out of the military
establishment something like a million
million-and-a-half or to out of the
foreign aid program
everything with you
expression of desire to cut by a great
many of these photos my house and senate
but there's no panic to make it
unless something you've done as you
suggested and myron was too cold air
supposedly chinese communists whites
into indochina others
wherever that may be a plan
do you mean by that panel that uh...
why don't we do with it should be
another great for scaring a serious
threat of immediate third war operation
desert liquid
well i think the answer that there is
simply that congress is always
concession these days unfortunately
remembered
and for the country sometime
so that and he uh...
legislation of the anak na
or any budget if we adopt now on the
assumption
networking for a long pull level them
because they live about twenty four hour
by congressional action
wrong with that
with your
book budget plan
tonight went uh... you know the
legislation
universal military training i don't
think it would affect the matter one way
or the other if the administration and
the professional military
honestly wanted u_n_c_
and were honestly deployment into
develop the u_n_ he is an alternative to
the present
and power of the large standing forces
will be enormous spending limit that i
don't i'm not so sure they meaning of it
that way and wait to see congressman for
our listeners tonight
can you tell us very quickly
just
how these budget arguments in congress
effect
the average american family
so that the average american family
itself what its dollars
will work
ten years ago and they will work on
birds and
and what they're worth
today in purchasing power at fifty three
cents
and one answer that question they'll
know what excessive bedroom spending the
done
uh... the devil
in inflation
fundamentally is fed groups
spending
of more money than you think in in texas
is the source of inflation and that they
want
every american is paying for every
morning on in the cosby breakfast food
and he can turn the radio news colony
are you saying that if your resolution
can be passed and if the government is
held to seventy one billion sd
standing here
that that will reduce the threat
inflation
i think it's for sure is playing limit
inflation under reestablish some
thing like found
financial
basis in the united states of the people
couldn't upload in some measure of his
cured
and certainly in their day-to-day
operations all would bar input
the possibility of an all-out war which
would upset all play
level courses your and resolution to
actually being realized
but the moment it's resting in a heavily
weighted
new deal committee of the house
uh... and great stepped forward was made
uh...
monday o tuesday when the republican
policy committee mana mostly in boston
over the very strong statement for
minority leader john martin of
massachusetts
i think that means that uh...
having maybe the party issue
our people will press forward and i'm
not democrat
have committed themselves for the
general proposition
substantial reduction
share a bit of a can be gotten to the
floor
it will be passed
now sir
there are some people i know we would
like to help you
would you mind and i'd like to your
predictions tube where you can do
something and whether you can get this
resolution passed in what ken india
average american who would like to help
you what did he do
who's familiar
despite any
fears of the country we are still living
in a free country
americans are still managed that they
didn't think to to assert
all we need in the room branch rupesh
room bolt
there is nothing more sensitive uh...
on earth in a member of congress in an
election year
only got to do with your the folks back
home and believe me they'll get action
now i returned to sum up brown's
i believed it usse you are trying to
forced the government to spend only
seventy one billion zan only what we
will be realize from taxes
that you think that you can accomplish
that
if they are not american citizens who
will try to their congressman and tried
to impose a system of economy on the
present government
thank you very much for being with us
the editorial board for this edition of
the long team colors go laws
colonel ansel java
and mister william bradford puri
our distinguished guests with the
honorable fred radar could add junior
united states representative from new
york
as for the olympic winter games it off
from wherever they come
will find the familiar touchable
in windows of fine jewelry store
long-chain
the world's most on that one
bought the frame of launching is
worldwide
in the month and i a city of not by the
bolivia and south america
all our historic happened
in painting breeds
city of mecca in saudi arabia
in any of the capitol though
comfort of the free world
the walk for the first place
with discriminating men and women
is long jane the world's most on it
the only watching history
to win ten world fair grand prizes
twenty eight gold medals
and higher five correct you're asleep on
the leading government there
along came off
and if you pay seventy one fifty or more
for a walk
oil so or as a gift
not paying the price of a laundry
why not insist on getting along jane
the world's most on that one
bring your product of the launching with
not what's happening
since eighteen sixty six
maker of what to tell the higher
laundry explosive professional wat
for the olympic winter games
of nineteen fifty two
this is pragmatic and
inviting you to join us every monday
wednesday and friday evening at the same
time
along team promised
television journal of the important
because of the hour
broadcast on behalf of launching
the world's most on that one
and whatnot distinguished companion to
the world on a long journey
so land surveyors from coast to coast
by more than four thousand leading to a
who proudly displayed at them
agency fall on gene with norwalk